this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream a subscription streaming
service that offers thousands of
documentaries
and non-fiction titles for just 299
a month get a 30-day free trial by
clicking the link in the description
below
more on them in just a bit
a mild-eyed man who killed 26
persons that was the title of an article
published in the new york sun in 1881
which detailed the exploits of bat
masterson even for the wild west
that was a huge number and almost
unheard of for a man of the law but
there was a pretty good reason this
wasn't heard of and that's because
it wasn't true the article was penned by
a gullible city reporter much too eager
to
learn and write about the rough and
tumble adventures on the frontier
but it was popular and exciting and it
got reprinted all over the country and
just like that
masterson's reputation was made as one
of the most feared gunslingers of the
west don't get us wrong though bam
masterson was no stranger to gunfights
as you're about to find out he has been
involved in a shootout or two and plenty
of other violent adventures but his body
count was way way lower
in fact during a libel trial while under
oath masterson estimated that it killed
three men and said that all of the
shootings had been justified
masterson was a man who had ambitions
that extended past the life of a
gunslinger and
most notably he actually got to fulfill
them once he
saw that his lawman days were over he
moved to new york city working various
jobs in the boxing world
then as a journalist a bodyguard to a
millionaire and even
as a presidential appointee by teddy
roosevelt batmasterson
might have been molded by the wild west
but he was one of the few to
outgrow and outlive it
[Music]
batmasterson was born bartholomew
william barclay masterson
on november 26 1853 in the municipality
of henryville
in quebec canada to thomas masterson and
catherine mcgurk him
a canadian farmer and her an irish
immigrant his parents had six other
children a particular note were his
brothers ed and james masterson who
would go on to become gunslinging lawmen
alongside batt although
neither one achieved his level of fame
in a very similar scenario to wyatt earp
and his two brothers virgil morgan the
origins of his nickname bat is a matter
of some dispute according to wild west
folklore masterson
earned the moniker while serving as a
lawman in dodge city he had been wounded
in a previous gunfight and
was forced to use a cane to walk around
although at first this was an impediment
masterson became proficient with his new
accessory and often used it as a club in
fights against rowdy cowboys and
thus came the nickname bat while this
would certainly fit his old west persona
it seems that
he was called bat before his lawmen days
and before
even getting shot according to the man
himself in his book famous gunfighters
of the western frontier he earned the
nickname
during his buffalo hunting days passed
on to him by a skilled hunter and
trapper named
baptiste brown also known as old bat
however
the book was a collection of newspaper
articles about wild west gunman with
a lot of drama and action so it's hard
to say exactly what was genuine and what
was embellished there is a third
much more mundane story which simply
says that his original name bartholomew
got
shortened to bart which then got
shortened to bat
he almost always referred to himself
under the name wb
bat masterson going back to his
childhood the masterson family left
canada when bat was just a boy and moved
around the united states quite a bit
before finally settling in kansas in
1871 on a large farm
near wichita by that point bat was 18
years old and was
ready to go out and find something to do
he was already skilled with guns so he
joined his older brother ed and became a
buffalo hunter and
the two of them were later joined by
james masterson it was during this time
that bat had already begun meeting some
other characters who would
go on to become part of the legend of
the wild west such as tom nixon
frontiersman billy dixon and
masterson's soon-to-be close friend
wyatt earp
already there were some stories that
helped build the reputation of
batmasterson on one occasion he and his
brother ed were stiffed on payment by a
contractor named raymond ritter who had
hired them to do some grading for the
santa fe railroad according to the story
it took
almost a year but finally tracked ritter
down coming into town by train he waited
for the train to pull into the station
entered ritter's compartment drew on him
and made him pay what he owed at
gunpoint
[Music]
on june 27 1874 batmasterson unwillingly
took part
in the second battle of adobe walls
against hundreds of comanche
cheyenne and kiowa warriors led by the
comanche chief quanah parker
adobe walls was a trading post built in
the texas panhandle and a decade prior
it was the site of one of the largest
conflicts to take place
on the great plains when a force of
around 400 soldiers and scouts led by
kit carson fought
thousands of native americans most of
them comanche and apache that battle
was inconclusive so now 10 years later
the southern plains bands again wanted
to try and destroy adobe walls and
push back the hunters who were quickly
dwindling the buffalo population
this time the scale of the conflict was
reduced significantly on one side there
were just 28 buffalo hunters who were
trapped inside adobe walls with 20 year
old batmasterson being the youngest of
the bunch
on the other side there were hundreds of
braves although the exact number is
disputed ranging anywhere between
250 and 700. in his memoir billy dixon
presented the scene there was never a
more splendidly barbaric sight
and after years i was glad that i had
seen it hundreds of warriors the
flower of the fighting men of the
southwestern plains tribes mounted upon
their finest horses
armed with guns and lances and carrying
heavy shields of thick buffalo hide were
coming like the wind
overall was splashed the rich colors of
red vermillion and
okra on the bodies of the men on the
bodies of the running horses
scalps dangled from their bridles
gorgeous warbonnets fluttered their
plumes bright feathers dangled from
the tails and manes of the horses and
the bronzed half-naked bodies of the
riders glittered with ornaments of
silver and brass
behind this headlong charging host
stretched the planes on whose horizon
the rising sun was lifting its morning
fires
the warriors seemed to emerge from this
glowing background
the battle consisted of a prolonged
siege but it ended with one phenomenal
shot that has become the stuff of legend
it belonged to the aforementioned billy
dixon who was
a renowned crack shot during a break in
the fight the buffalo hunters saw a
group of enemy riders gathering on a
ridge almost a mile away to
survey the situation dixon then so came
with a 50-90 sharps rifle and
dropped one of the warriors cleanly with
one bullet allegedly the comanche was so
disheartened by the shot that they gave
up the siege as far as masterson was
concerned he acquitted himself well
during the fighting and later enrolled
as a civilian scout in the red river war
which took place on the southern plains
as a direct result
of the siege at adobe walls
[Music]
after his enrollment finished masterson
spent some more time hunting buffalo and
gambling in saloons until
he headed out to dodge city and became a
lawman before that though
there was the event that left him with a
limp and forced him
to use a cane it was january 1876 and
masterson was still
hanging around the army camp near adobe
walls one night during a card game batt
got into an argument with corporal
melvin king of the fourth u.s cavalry
allegedly over a prostitute named molly
brennan the argument evolved into a
fight and king pulled out a gun and
fired however during the scuffle molly
brennan got between the two men trying
to stop the fight king's bullet
accidentally hit her in the stomach
then came out the other side and struck
masterson in the pelvis
in return batt pulled out his own gun
and shot king dead although
brennan also died of her injuries there
is another version of the story which
simply says that both masterson and king
were involved in a fight between
multiple buffalo hunters and soldiers
king was the only fatality but it wasn't
even known if masterson
was the one who shot him in retrospect
given bats fame the first
story was the one that became popular by
may that same year batmasterson had
recovered and
made his way to dodge city kansas a city
that has become synonymous with the old
west alongside the likes of tombstone
and deadwood
and is considered emblematic of those
wild frontier days
when masterson rode into town the man in
charge was charlie bassett another
notable character
of the old west who was serving both the
city marshal of dodge city and
sheriff of ford county kansas by 1877
batt was made an undersheriff for ford
county
while his brother ed became deputy
marshall wyatt also served as a lawman
in dodge city during this time
before moving on to tombstone by the end
of the year bassett's term as sheriff
was ending and
by kansas law he wasn't allowed to seek
a third term therefore he
backed masterson as a candidate for
sheriff of port county the local
newspapers described masterson as a
young man
of nerve and coolness in cases of danger
he has served on the police force of
this city and
also as undersheriff and knows just how
to gather in
the sinners he is well qualified to fill
the office and
if elected will never shrink from danger
batmasterson was elected as the new
sheriff in november and he took office
in january 1878. he went on to appoint
charlie bassett as his new undersheriff
and his brother
aired as the new city marshal of dodge
city james masterson joined them a
little bit later now we're going to join
mr masterson
and co in kansas in just a moment but
first i want to take a second to thank
today's video sponsor
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries
and non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals curiosity
stream is available on many platforms
and web apps including roku android xbox
one smart tvs ios chromecast
amazon fire the list goes on if you've
got a screen you're probably going to be
able to watch it it's also offered
worldwide and is constantly updated with
amazing
timely content if you're enjoying this
video why not check out pioneering the
american frontier on curiosity stream or
maybe you'd like their series
on the rails which profiles different
areas of the world from the perspective
of rail travel
both excellent choices go to
curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics
for unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series and
right now
as a special deal for you guys you can
get a free 30-day trial
to try out curiosity stream just use the
code biography check out it's a great
way to support the show
and let's get back to bat
there were three notable events that
marked batmasterson's stint
as sheriff of fort county the first was
exactly the kind of thing you would
expect
from the wild west in his second month
in office masterson and his posse chased
down a gang of dangerous train robbers
led by a notorious outlaw named dirty
dave rudibar however they managed to
capture two of the criminals in an
ambush and arrested them without a
shootout while the other two were
apprehended soon after the second event
was considerably more violent
and left two men dead on april 9 1878
city marshal ed masterson approached a
drunken cowboy named jack wagner
who was causing a ruckus in town he
tried to get him to disarm but instead
wagner drew on ed and shot him
marshall shot back and put the cowboy in
the chest then stumbled into a nearby
saloon where
he said what had happened before he
collapsed ed masterson died about a half
hour later
killed in the line of duty while wagner
also died the next day in different
versions of the story wagner escaped the
altercation unharmed but
once matt found out what he'd done he
tracked down his brother's killer
and gunned him down himself the third
incident that marked masterson's tenure
as sheriff of fort county was
known as the royal gorge war which was
in reality a dispute between two
railroads over who had the right
to lay track through the royal gorge
these sort of conflicts were common back
then and were known as the railroad
wars as numerous different companies
vied for supremacy in this particular
case it was a dispute between the denver
and rio grande railroad and the atchison
topeka
and santa fe railroad such companies
often employed gunfighters as an
intimidation tactic although the
official reason was to ensure that their
interests were protected this time it
was the santa fe railroad that hired
batmasterson to
look after their interests which
involved him assembling a group of 60 or
so men
and even obtaining a cannon should the
need for one arise
the gunslingers in masterson's employ
were a who's who of the wild west
including
doc holliday ben thompson mysterious
dave mather and
even the man he once arrested dirty dave
rudebar
for something that had the word war in
it and took place during the wild west
and involved some of that period's most
dangerous shooters
the royal gorge war was surprisingly
tame most of it was fought in courtrooms
while the hired men kept their guns
holstered and
mainly relied on threats and
intimidations there is still dispute
over if anyone was actually killed
during the conflict
or not some sources say no while others
claim that a man named henry jenkins was
shot in the back by a drunken guard
eventually it was the supreme court who
settled the matter
and sided with the rio grande railroad
thus forcing masterson and his posse to
surrender their positions
[Music]
we're not sure if his role in the royal
gorge war tainted his reputation
somewhat but masterson lost his
re-election bid for ford county sheriff
in 1880. for the next few years he
drifted from town to town mainly
operating as a gambler and
occasional car dealer at the fiery
tables however there were a couple of
instances where he showed
that he was willing to leave everything
behind to go and help his friends in
need
most famous of all was the so-called
battle of the plaza in april
1881. at that point bat was in tombstone
working in the oriental saloon alongside
wyatt earp when he received a telegram
from his brother james masterson saying
that he was in danger
and needed help in dodge city bat had
already lost one brother he didn't want
to lose another
he jumped on the first train and arrived
in dodge city on april the 16th
because telegrams were usually short
masterson didn't really have any idea of
his brother's predicament
he knew that james had been arguing with
a former business partner named aj
peacock and his brother-in-law
al abdegraf and he clearly feared for
his life otherwise he would not have
sent the telegram that was all bat
needed as it happened he spotted peacock
and upped graph as he was getting off
the train
it's possible that they were waiting for
him knowing that james masterson would
have sent word for help
that called out to them but they weren't
in the talking mood they drew their guns
and opened fire that dove for cover and
did the same during the shootout a
couple of masterson's old friends exited
the long branch saloon and
joined in in the gunfight but so did a
few gunmen from peacock's side
eventually updraft fell to the ground
moaning as a bullet pissed his lungs
who shot it we don't know but that was
the end of the fight just as well as
masterson had run out of bullets
when the mayor approached him shotgun in
hand bet simply surrendered his guns and
asked how his brother was doing he was
fine by the way
and since it couldn't be proven who shot
optograph masterson was only fined eight
dollars for unlawfully discharging his
gun on a city street
he and james left dodge city together
and a while later ended up in trinidad
colorado
where they once again served as lawmen
in 1882 ben masterson became the city
marshal of trinidad during his tenure he
used his influence at the behest of
wyatt earp to
save doc holliday who had been arrested
in denver for a shooting committed in
arizona holliday risked deportation to
arizona where he and the earps had a lot
of enemies eager for revenge instead
masterson helped him in colorado by
filing bongo charges against holliday to
delay proceedings and
then finally convincing the colorado
governor to reject the extradition
altogether
oddly enough the most notable event from
this era did not happen in trinidad but
back in dodge city in april 1883 he
received word that one of his friends
back there luke short needed help once
again masterson didn't hesitate and
boarded the train for dodge city
timing-wise it worked out great because
he'd just lost his re-election bid for
city marshall so there wasn't anything
keeping him in trinidad
luke short was a partner in the infamous
long branch saloon
and he butted heads with the new mayor
lawrence dagger the latter wanted the
saloon closed and short gone when legal
measures failed short claimed that
dagger along with the police and the
city marshal unofficially organized a
vigilante group to
drive him out of town under threat of
violence he petitioned the governor who
sided with short but only gave him a
10-day window in which he would be able
to return to dodge city and sell the
saloon
back in town it was made clear to short
that if he was still around after those
10 days
bad things were going to happen that is
when he sent word to his friends and
quite a few of them answered the call
there was batmasterson wyatta charlie
bassett shotgun john collins and
about a half a dozen others this became
known as the dodge city war although
once again the word war is a bit
disingenuous here there was no fighting
degre's posse knew better than to start
a shootout with some of the west's most
feared gunmen but
ultimately it was basic economics that
settled the matter when all of short's
allies arrived in dodge city mayor
dagger ordered all the saloons bars and
gambling halls closed
this was at the height of the cattle
drive season and all the business owners
complained that the mayor's actions were
destroying the city's economy
eventually he relented and the dodge
city war ended without a single shot
fired
and short did sell the saloon a few
months later the most memorable moment
of the
whole affair ended up being a photograph
of luke short batmasterson
wyatt earp and the other gunman dubbed
the dodge city peace commission it
became one of the most widely reproduced
images of the old west
the dodge city war was more or less
batmasterson's last hurrah as
a fearsome gunslinger of the wild west
from then on he tried living a more
docile life focused on
some of his other interests he started
with journalism and published his first
newspaper called the vox papooli in
1884.
it only lasted one issue and although
masterson would eventually find success
as a journalist
that time had not yet arrived in 1886
masterson left dodge city behind once
more and
moved to denver where he had various
jobs related to gambling such as
faro dealer and gambling hall manager
around this time
he met and befriended a notorious con
man named sophie smith whom
we already covered in a previous
biographics video during the 1890s
masterson engaged in two more of his
interests
boxing and mining he had been a boxing
fan for a while and attended numerous
bouts so
eventually he got to serve in an
official capacity as a timekeeper
promoter or second as far as mining was
concerned that masterson briefly
relocated to creed colorado which
had become a silver boom town while
there he managed a gambling house called
the denver exchange and
also served as unofficial lawman we say
unofficial because he didn't have any
sort of authority but as one newspaper
described the situation
masterson was generally recognized in
the camp as the
nerviest man of all the fighters here
all the tops and thugs fear him as they
do no
other dozen men in camp let an incipient
ride start and all that is necessary to
quell it
is the whisper there comes masterson
clearly his fearsome reputation still
preceded him wherever he went and it was
the same reputation that helped
masterson land his next gig
which was also the cushiest job he'd
ever have in 1895 he entered the employ
of railroad tycoon george gould the
son of jay gould one of america's most
notorious robber baron
and again someone we've already covered
here on biographics george gould had
been receiving threatening letters from
an anonymous person and
thought that it would be prudent to hire
a bodyguard someone who not only had the
skills but
also an intimidating presence on a
friend's recommendation he offered the
job to batmasterson
and began paddling around with the
country's wealthy elite
always at gould's side life was lush for
martissan he wrote to friends back in
denver telling them how he would spend
the whole day fishing on a yacht or how
he'd go to the races where gould would
give him thousands of dollars to
bet as he pleased but unfortunately all
good things must come to an end and the
bodyguard gig finished for masterson
after about eight months when
gould's letter writer was finally
arrested
[Music]
it was time for bat to return to denver
but he developed a taste for life in the
big apple
he wanted to move to new york but the
time wasn't right yet so he went back to
colorado
and he continued where he left off
masterson became a partner in a boxing
club and he also began
writing a weekly sports column for a
denver newspaper called george's weekly
this went on for a few more years until
bat left colorado permanently and
relocated to new york city in 1902.
his arrival was not an auspicious one
soon afterwards he was
arrested for allegedly running a crooked
faro game and was then sued by a mormon
elder from salt lake city named george
snow
who claimed that he had been hustled out
of 16 000 it was during this trial that
the newspaper article written about
masterson 20 years earlier came back
into the spotlight the one
that was highly exaggerated and asserted
that the former lawman had killed almost
30 people
it was also at this time that bat
finally set the record straight
about his wild west exploits as far as
the suit was concerned it was dismissed
when
snow didn't shop for the hearing
masterson was only fined 10
for carrying a concealed weapon but now
he filed a countersuit against his
accuser
due to damages caused to his reputation
and good name as it turns out snow had
never specified masterson by name in his
affidavit
the case was settled out of court but
that put the blame on his arresting
officers
claiming that they took him for a sucker
and tried to pin the charges on him once
that initial unpleasantness was dealt
with new york city became bat's home for
the last 20 years of his life his
journalistic career flourished becoming
a regular columnist for the morning
telegraph but also occasional writer for
other publications he mainly covered
boxing and
would always be found ringside at every
big bout in the country
masterson also struck up a friendship
with president theodore roosevelt who
had a lot of admiration for
the rough and tough wild west lawmen but
also shared a lot of boxing roosevelt
appointed masterson deputy u.s marshal
for the southern district of new york
it sounded fancy but the position mainly
involved bat providing security in the
grand jury room while core was in
session
it lasted until taft became president as
he abolished the job since he didn't
share his predecessor's fondness of the
old west on october 25
1921 the 67 year old batmasterson had
finished writing his column and
then had a heart attack and died at his
desk he was then buried at the woodlawn
cemetery in the bronx following a
service attended by hundreds of friends
and admirers his death was quiet and
peaceful not something that
most other wild west figures get to
experience that masterson is a rare
example of someone who managed to
escape the old west and successfully
build a new life for himself
in the modern era so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below
don't forget to subscribe and also
please do check out our fantastic
sponsor curiosity stream
there's a link below and thank you for
[Music]
watching